c'est l'un des châteaux phare en vente
en bourgogne ce début d'année une
demeure bicentenaire de 450 mètres
carrés au nord de mâcon avec une
parcelle d'un hectare un terrain
piscinable huit chambres six salles de
bains et trois salons en enfilade
on est loin des châteaux médiévaux avec
douvres pour le vix et tourelles mais
c'est précisément ce type de bien qui
correspond aujourd'hui aux demandes
beaucoup de futurs acquéreurs sans
presti si c'est un bien qu'on a on
vendre depuis un mois on a déjà effectué
cinq visites sur ce bien d'autres sont
encore à programmer à prévoir donc
arrête très soutenu cette propriété
partira dans quelques semaines sans
aucun souci avant la crise sanitaire
cela aurait mis entre six mois et un an
pour se vendre désormais si les
échéances sont plus rapides
c'est que les châteaux non plus la même
vocation comment c'est une résidence
secondaire et ce qui est tout à fait
intéressant et pour l'instant les toutes
les demandes quasiment que nous avons
eues sur cette maison on voit de plus en
plus les urbains notamment kipré
investissent les campagnes donc à
l'avenir de toute évidence la maison
deviendra une résidence principale et
c'est des éléments qu'on voit de plus en
plus de manière fréquente en réalité
cela fait dix ans que les transactions
de châteaux ont doublé les agences
spécialisées recense environ 1500 bien
en vente en france 10% d'entre eux se
trouveraient en bourgogne où chaque
année au moins 20 château change de
mains les prix peuvent aller de 500
mille euros à plus de 3 millions suivant
la superficie où l'ampleur des travaux
ce qui reste très juteux pour les
agences immobilières
certaines ont augmenté leur chiffre
d'affaires de 50 % en 2020 grâce
uniquement à ses ventes comme celle où
travaillent isabelle ponelle depuis le
début de l'année elle a déjà vendu trois
châteaux en bourgogne
il ya beaucoup de châteaux à vendre il
ya beaucoup de gens qui vendent leur
château parce que les enfants ne veulent
pas reprendre le château parce que ça
coûte très cher elles et ils peuvent pas
le château il faut savoir quand même que
parfois c'est un gouffre
faute de succession familiale les
châteaux tombent parfois aux mains
d'investisseurs étrangers ce qui a déjà
causé quelques scandales dans la région
à nogent lès montbard avec ce bien
acquis par un franco suisse en 2010 est
laissé à l'abandon depuis ou encore
celui de la rochepot saisis par la
justice depuis trois ans après avoir été
racheté par un ukrainien soupçonné de
corruption et de blanchiment d'argent
arcelor côte-d'or une association de
châteaulin s'inquiètent depuis longtemps
de ces dérives et ce regain d'intérêt ne
les rassure pas pour autant les nouveaux
profils d'acheteurs iront souvent au
bout des travaux mais pour en faire des
propriétés privées ou des hôtels de luxe
à terme ils craignent que les châteaux
perdent de leur intérêt patrimonial les
monuments aux questions ont toutes leurs
chances d'être bien replieront en charge
bien veste aurait bien d'autres plus il
n'y a pas de problème mais par contre il
ya risque de sortir du de la du nombre
de châteaux ouverts à la visite
alors c'est un très très gros problème
surtout pour l'attractivité touristique
de la france
même quand on y vit comme moi même j'ai
pu le vivre à are ce lot eh bien on
découvre encore plein de choses sur
notre sur notre monument on est encore
en train de découvrir des des
architectes connus qui ont contribué par
exemple au jardin et il serait dommage
que ce patrimoine français soient perdus
sombre dans l'oubli
en france on estime à 20 mille le nombre
de châteaux vendus à des fins privées
uniquement des biens qui sont
généralement remis en vente
dix ans plus tard